another iconic multiplayer game that was
recently announced rainbow six mobile
let's take a quick look at what the dev
team have in store for us following
their successful closed alpha test
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm justin swann creative
director of rainbow six mobile
it's been a big exciting year for our
game with the worldwide announcement and
our first close alpha taking place
earlier this year it was amazing finally
getting to see how our players and
community reacted to the game and we
couldn't be happier with the initial
feedback
rainbow six mobile is a free-to-play
game designed from the ground up
specifically for mobile devices when we
started production our objective was
crystal clear to bring the rainbow six
universe to the mobile platform and
allow more people than ever before from
all around the world to enjoy this
competitive tactical and team-based fps
experience
our mission is to develop the best
rainbow six experience possible on
mobile and we can only do that with your
help
the dev team and i first want to thank
our community for all your support and
feedback during our close alpha
we took that feedback to heart and we've
made many improvements and it's not just
the core gameplay but our menu systems
and user experience matchmaking and
roundaround flow and many other
adjustments that will improve the
overall experience
all thanks to you
and now today
i'm very happy to announce that we are
entering a new phase for rainbow six
mobile the beta test
the closed beta starts this monday
september 12th and the good news is that
android users can still pre-register on
google play for a chance to participate
just a quick note for our ios users
don't worry we are working hard on our
ios version and you will hear from us in
the near future for upcoming tests
so what can you expect to see in the
game during the beta test
our biggest addition is the first stage
of our operator unlock and progression
system this means daily challenges to
complete a ticket system to play with
and unlock your operators and even a
battle pass to progress through on top
of that we have some great graphical and
gameplay improvements social features
like voice chat and persistent teams and
a more streamlined menu flow
you will also be able to compete in
three iconic rainbow six maps
bank
border and the newly added
clubhouse
keep in mind this is still a work in
progress version of the game graph
quality and content are much improved
from our alpha test but still not final
as we continue along this exciting road
to release we must move forward
alongside you our players and fans we
believe this is the only way to deliver
the best game experience possible and we
are dedicated to developing rainbow six
mobile in as transparent and
collaborative way as possible with our
players
now
you may be wondering in which countries
the closed beta will be available
starting this monday
well you'll find the answers in this
next video
thank you for all your support and see
you in the closed beta
[Music]
it's a top a thing
i'm ready
[Music]
back
[Music]
[Music]
you